alizée puisse acheter des mines
inexploitables ce n'est pas explicable
mais ça permet d'envoyer aussi des
gratifications on va dire à des à des
politiciens nigérien la gestion
fantaisiste d'areva a des répercussions
incroyable jusqu'au président américain
obama donne son accord pour qu'areva
bénéficie d'un prêt de 2 milliards de
dollars alors que l'agent ce qui est
censé gérer ces prêts un avis négatif
je ne suis pas pour ou contre le
nucléaire je suis simplement pour une
industrie sans corruption parce que
cette industrie là si elle créait un
incident c'est pour l'éternité
[Musique]
commémoration des attentats du 13
novembre 2015 à paris en comité
restreint autour de jean castex ou de
gérald darmanin des attaques coordonnées
contre le stade de france le bataclan et
les terrasses des cafés avaient fait au
moins 130 morts et des centaines de
victimes
pour contrer la menace terroriste
islamiste les pays de l'union européenne
préconise une réponse coordonnée et
rapide avec un renforcement des
frontières extérieures de l'europe
l approche des élections régionales et
départementales en mars prochain un
report de trois mois recommandée par
l'ancien président du conseil
constitutionnel mandaté par matignon
jean louis debré conseille aussi de
faciliter les procurations et de
développer le vote en ligne et par
correspondance
la question fait polémique alors que le
vote aux états unis n'est toujours pas
stabilisée dix jours après le scrutin
des manifestations en arménie contre
l'accord de paix signé pour le haut
karabagh à un accord qui a mis fin à six
semaines de conflit meurtrier
près de 2000 soldats de maintien de la
paix russes vont être déployés dans les
zones disputées une question de survie
pour la république autoproclamée à
majorité arménienne
[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue sur rt france à la une
de l'actualité ce vendredi les
commémorations des attentats du 13
novembre 2015 à paris il y a cinq ans un
commando armé projeté de la zone irako
syrienne assassiné plus de 230 personnes
dans des attaques quasi simultanées
le stade de france à saint denis les
terrasses des cafés à paris et la salle
du concert du bataclan commémoration en
petit comité vous le voyez à cause du
virus en présence du chef du
gouvernement et du ministre de
l'intérieur une menace toujours bien
réelle cinq ans après après les récents
attentats en france et en autriche les
ministres de l'intérieur de l'union
européenne se sont retrouvés aujourd'hui
à bruxelles les pays qui préconise une
réponse coordonnée et rapide avec un
renforcement des frontières extérieures
de l'europe afin de contrer la menace
terroriste islamiste
il souhaite également mettre en place
une législation européenne afin de faire
retirer en moins d'une heure les
contenus à caractère terroriste sur
internet
les états membres devraient transposer
et mettre en oeuvre dans leur
intégralité les instruments existants
tels que le système d'information
schengen et la directive sur les armes à
feu
également mentionnés par le ministre sy
hofer et s'assurer qu'il y à des
contrôles systématiques à nos frontières
extérieures et pour en parler nous
sommes avec rené georges querry ancien
patron de l'unité de coordination de la
lutte antiterroriste
bonsoir rené georges querry merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous sur rt france
alors ces dernières années l'union
européenne a beaucoup développé la
surveillance de ses frontières et a
notamment partagé ses informations entre
les états membres
mais on le voit cela ne suffit pas pour
endiguer la menace terroriste
tout d'abord la menace terroriste telle
qu'elle existe depuis dans 5 ans 6 ans
est d'abord et surtout endogène elle a
été réalisée certes par des gens ne sont
venus de l'extérieur
le bataclan on a vu et aussi ces
derniers et trois derniers attentats ont
été commis par des immigrés mais
globalement c'est au sein des pays que
naissent et se développent cette menace
que c'est de ce risque terroriste
mais il est vrai qu'il faut renforcer
les frontières alors le problème
évidemment de ne pas faire une
assimilation un peu facile entre
immigration et terrorisme tous les
immigrés ne sont pas des terroristes
et là c'est trois derniers terroristes
étaient des immigrés mais je crois
surtout que la priorité c'est de lutter
contre l'immigration mais qui doit être
une action malgré taux différencié de la
lutte contre le terrorisme alors la
différencier compliqué puisque les
personnes se sont présentées comme des
comme des migrants ils ont même pour
certains obtenu l'asile
comment faire pour la différencier selon
vous c'est très compliqué surtout s'il
n'y a pas de passif sur ces personnes
non c'est effectivement très compliqué
c'est un risque avec un risque avec
lequel nous devons vivre mais je crois
surtout que parmi les annonces qui ont
été faites
'l'annonce la plus importante est celle
qui concerne la maîtrise des
informations tout ce qui est la
situation à la haine
on a vu dans la sphère de l'assassinât
de bâti de samuel bâti que une fatwa
avait quasiment été lancée sur internet
pour être perçu 80 km plus loin par un
tchétchène qui est venu assassiné ce
professeur et je pense que un des points
importants sur lequel l'union européenne
viennent travailler et qui doit être
mise en oeuvre
c'est effectivement
mieux utiliser éventuellement couper
toutes les informations qui concernent
la polo gillan incitation à la haine ne
sera pas attentatoire aux libertés
individuelles
parce que la première des libertés c'est
de ne pas être assassiné à faire retirer
justement les contenus à caractère
terroriste dans l'eure c'est ce que veut
l'union européenne est ce que cela vous
paraît faisable
ça ça demande aussi la contribution des
dégâts pas alors bon mois les gaffes a
normalement il doit faire ce chrono de
ce que leur dit de faire
c'est l'état qui doit maîtriser le
dispositif
une députée avait tenté une projet de
loi en juin dernier qui a été cassée par
le conseil constitutionnel où il
s'agissait effectivement d'aller un
petit peu maîtrisé cette information à
écouter faut savoir ce que l'on veut
c'est toujours l'éternel problème entre
la sécurité des gens la liberté
d'information mais là il s'agit de
d'éviter de diffuser du feu l'un sur la
toile je pense qu'il n'y a pas
d'atteinte aux libertés individuelles
comment améliorer également la
surveillance des frontières extérieures
de schengen ce qui voudrait dire qu'à
l'intérieur on peut circuler comme on
veut ça demande quel effort
supplémentaire
il y à déjà frontex qui le fait mais
comment améliorer les frontières
extérieures selon vous de l'union
européenne
oui alors ça c'est effectivement un
problème énorme
on est toujours dans des logis
technocratique on parle de fond traict
frontex les frontières extérieures
si vous regardez la carte européenne de
schengen ça représente quasiment tous
les pays de l'union de l'europe de
l'ouest à l'exception de l'angleterre
est aujourd'hui des balkans c'est quand
même énorme qu'il s'agisse des
frontières terrestres qu'il s'agisse des
frontières maritimes
on voit bien tous ces clandestins qui
essaient d'arriver en italie aux risques
aux deux au péril de leur vie les
frontières alors dans les aéroports ça
marche plutôt bien parce qu'il ya un
passage obligé un contrôle auquel il est
difficile de se soustraire
mais après c'est tout le problème des
frontières terrestres et maritimes
et effectivement je pense que là on
n'est pas encore sorti de l'auberge
pour le contrôle des frontières
terrestres et marines
il concerne le partage des informations
qui s'est déjà beaucoup entre les 27
pays membres est ce que cela vous paraît
suffisant ou faut-il renforcer aussi cet
aspect là alors je pense ou leur déjà le
premier point en france on est vraiment
dans une situation de smos notamment
entre la dgse la dgsi l'interview
aujourd'hui de bernard emié et de
nicolas lerner dans un grand quotidien
montre bien qu'en france franchement on
joue collectif comme aurait dit aimé
jacquet et on est vraiment dans une
bonne cohérence dans une bonne cohésion
après à l'échelon européenne c'est peut
être un peu plus compliqué chaque pays a
son propre fichier
chaque pays a sa propre technique sa
propre technologie
la fluidité n'est peut-être pas aussi le
forte qu'on pourrait l'imaginer surtout
content qu'on pourrait le souhaiter
alors là il y aura probablement des
efforts à faire mais c'est plus à mon
avis une question de technologie
d'harmonisation la technique entre les
différents fichiers que de volonté la
volonté politique elle existe
et croyez-moi relation européen elle
existe déjà depuis 30 ans notamment à
l'époque on déjà vu en lutte et déjà
contre eux contre ce que l'on appelait
leur terrorisme la volonté européenne
existe vous dit
existe-t-elle vraiment lorsqu'il s'agit
d'opérations extérieures comme c'est le
cas notamment de l'implication de la
france au mali
est ce que la volonté existe aussi à ce
niveau là de contrer sur le terrain les
terroristes alors là c'est un autre
sujet si effectivement il y a une
volonté européenne réel pour protéger le
territoire et les haies les citoyens
européens même si la citoyenneté
européenne mais de protéger les gens sur
le territoire européen
à l'étranger c'est différent n'a pas
encore une diplomatie européenne n'a pas
encore une armée européenne et est
évident que sur ce plan là à mes yeux
moi je fais pas un grand spécialiste des
questions internationales mais je pense
que la france qui s'engage avec courage
et détermination au moyen-orient et en
afrique pour justement maîtrise et
essayer de contrôler la montée de
l'islamisme dans ces pays là en sachant
que ça peut déborder sur l'europe et
bien
je le dis la france je la trouve bien
seul dans ce combat
merci beaucoup rené georges querry
d'avoir répondu ce soir en direct à nos
questions sur rt france et en france
justement l approche des élections
régionales et départementales en mars
prochain un report de trois mois a été
recommandée par l'ancien président du
conseil constitutionnel dans un rapport
remis à matignon jean louis debré qui
conseille également de faciliter les
procurations et de développer le vote en
ligne ou par correspondance
c'est une question qui fait polémique
quand on voit ce que ce qu'il se passe
aux etats unis
la crainte c'est évidemment la fraude
solène gaudin et sébastien dufour c'est
peut-être de cette façon que vous
voterez pour les prochaines élections
départementales et régionales de mars
2021 votre bulletin de vote
envoyé par la poste en tout cas c'est ce
que propose des députés de la majorité
et nous nous sommes rendus à l'assemblée
nationale pour leur demander pourquoi je
pense que ça peut être un bourreau mais
de sueur sur l'abstention d'avis aux
élections municipales qu'il y avait
moins de personnes d'un certain âge qui
avaient voté et donc ça peut altérer la
sincérité du scrutin s'ils viennent pas
voter le vote par correspondance permet
d'avoir un spectre plus large
de votants donc d'être plus honnête par
rapport à la volonté du peuple
si on l'installé store pour toutes les
élections je vois pas pourquoi le ferait
uniquement pour les régionales d'une
départementale ou alors on se dit que
c'est parce qu'il ya la crise sanitaire
effectivement si on veut maintenir ces
élections que ça serait une possibilité
pour que tous les électeurs puissent
exprimer leur vote démocratique
alors est ce qu'on aura le temps de le
mettre en place pour les régir et
départementales je ne sais pas mais en
tout cas la réflexion sur un vote par
correspondance qui maintenant peut être
relativement facilement sécurisé par
rapport aux as par rapport aux années où
il avait été arrêté pour les raisons de
fraude me paraît justifié donc moi je
vote oui pour le vote par correspondance
les scrutins régionaux et départementaux
pourrait être repoussé au mois de juin
jean louis debré l'ex président du
conseil constitutionnel remette un
rapport à ce sujet au gouvernement ce
vendredi
mais c'est une proposition qui surprend
en effet aux etats-unis le vote par
correspondance fait polémique en ce
moment soissons 4 millions d'électeurs
ont fait ce choix pour le vote pour la
présidentielle du 3 novembre dernier
mais sa légitimité risque d'être remise
en cause mais pour l'instant en france
le gouvernement restent frileux à
l'égard de cette idée c'est le risque de
fraude qui inquiète l'exécutif le
système électoral français fonctionne il
correspond sans doute à un certain
nombre de critères qui empêche peut-être
d'aller vers le vote à distance et cela
pour plusieurs raisons
pas d'isolement possible risque de
pressions de proches pour influencer le
vote risque d'arriver tardive des
bulletins qui pourraient différés lé
annonce des résultats des élections
comme aux états unis avec en plus des
interrogations sur la date d'envoi des
dix bulletins difficulté à vérifier
parfaitement l'identité des citoyens
votant à distance car la france a déjà
éprouvé ce système de 1918 et 1945 il
était possible de voter de cette façon
dans l'hexagone mais ce procédé a été
supprimé par le gouvernement chirac sous
la présidence de valéry giscard
d'estaing
c'était le 12 novembre 1975 il y a tout
juste 45 ans le vote par correspondance
a été remplacé par le vote par
procuration toujours en vigueur
cette proposition est revenu à plusieurs
reprises à l'assemblée nationale
la dernière fois c'était en 2017 mais
elle n'a jamais abouti
le vote par correspondance est une sorte
de serpent de mer mais qui pourrait bien
cette fois fort surface pour de bon à
cause de l'épidémie de choléra dont la
question du vote par correspondance fait
débat jean christophe lagarde président
de l'udps et i l n'y est pas favorable
il l'a expliqué sur notre antenne tout à
l'heure regarder trouvé le prétexte
l'antonyme et de l'abstention pour dire
ah si on faciliter la vie aux gens par
correspondance sert correspond bien sûr
à une toute petite part des lecteurs
mais elle est marginal le désintérêt il
est plus nier les difficultés politiques
dans débat politique que dans le mode de
vote
non s'il ya une possibilité d'avancer
par un vote différent ce serait
peut-être je dis bien peut-être sur le
vote par le vote électronique ont fait
aujourd'hui beaucoup de courses beaucoup
d' échanges financiers vous payez par
l'internet
donc on est capable d'identifier monde
est capable de sécuriser votre compte
bancaire etc ça je pense que c'est sans
doute envisageable ce que je ne sais pas
c'est si on permettait de
l'identification de l'électeur et le
vote de l'électeur par internet qui me
paraît beaucoup plus sécurisée cavok
sous l'angle
je ne sais pas si on est capable
d'assurer que mon bulletin de vote va
être bien content et entendez bien que
si sur mon ordinateur je prêche sur la
touche biden je veux pas que y est un
logiciel qui transforme sa de temps en
temps votre le professeur didier raoult
tu vas bien comparaître devant les
instances disciplinaires de l'ordre des
médecins pour avoir fait la promotion de
l'hydroxyde chloroquine le médecin
marseillais est l'objet de plusieurs
plaintes
quentin auclair controversé depuis qu'a
commencé la crise sanitaire
le professeur de médecine marseillais
didier rahout va devoir s'expliquer
devant les instances disciplinaires de
l'ordre des médecins
cette convocation dévoilé ce jeudi par
le conseil national de l'ordre des
médecins découle d'une plainte déposée
en juillet dernier par la société de
pathologie infectieuse de langue
française
d'après le magazine paris match l'as
cliff reproche au médecin d'avoir
utilisé des traitements non validé ainsi
que d'avoir manqué aux devoirs de
confraternité didier rahout avait
également fait l'objet de plusieurs
signalements de patients mais aussi
d'autres médecins
on va arrêter d'être dans les débats
scientifiques au et kiko politico
médiatique on va arrêter d'être dans la
vindicte populaire
en tout cas de cette frange marginale de
la profession pourrait être sur le
terrain rigoureux du droit et sur le
terrain du droit
diddy raul effectivement n'a absolument
rien à craindre de voilà deux ordres des
médecins n'a rien à craindre
effectivement de cette comparution
devant un champ disciplinaire je le
redis il a hâte en ce qu il entend
effectivement s'expliquer précisément et
sortira de là avec son honneur lavé la
question qu'on peut raisonnablement se
poser en sera-t-il de même pour les
institutions ordinales ou alors est-ce
qu'elles ne seront pas ridiculiser
mi-septembre le microbiologiste avait
déjà été entendu par la commission d'
enquête du sénat seul face aux sénateurs
ils avaient défendu son traitement un
l'hydroxyde chloroquine contre le
nouveau coronavirus lui qui mène depuis
plusieurs mois des essais cliniques avec
cette molécule
c'est pas moi qui développe l'enquêté je
les dis encore la semaine dernière donc
c'est pas moi qui ai développement que
j'étais donc le l'interdiction
préinscrire tout le monde c'est mon
opinion dessus si vous voulez mais là
encore je vois pas comment on aurait pu
avoir un débat serein quand en espace de
d'une demi journée
on sait le ministère et le msc mis à
dire on interdit partout l'hydroxyde
rockin parce que ça tue les gens pour un
papier qui a été retiré trois semaines
après parce que c'était une bande de
pieds nickelés qui avait écrit ce truc
dont personne ne savait d'où il sortait
donc c'est à moi qui raconte des bêtises
quand même faire au bout d'un moment il
faut revenir sur terre c'est pas moins
quarante ponts des bêtises
accusé de plusieurs entorses à la
déontologie didier rahout aura le temps
de se préparer avant d'être auditionné
par ses pairs d'après le conseil
national de l'ordre des médecins
le délai de traitement de ce type de
plainte est en moyenne de 10 mois les
inégalités toujours en hausse en france
sont les conclusions du dernier rapport
du secours catholique publié avant-hier
une situation qui pourrait s'aggraver
avec la crise sanitaire
jonathan moldave et robin qu elle la
france pourrait dépasser le seuil
symbolique des 10 millions de pauvres en
2020 c'est le constat dressé par la
présidente du secours catholique
en marge de la publication du rapport
annuel de l'association sur l'état de la
pauvreté dans l'hexagone en 2018 selon
l'insee la france comptait 9,3 millions
de personnes vivant sous le seuil de
pauvreté monétaire soit avec moins de
1000 63 euros par mois une situation qui
pourrait empirer à cause des
conséquences économiques et sociales de
la crise sanitaire
toutes les personnes qui sont en
situation de pauvreté risquent d'être
les oubliés de cette crise elles sont
souvent amenés à continuer à travailler
quand elles le peuvent
elles sont souvent amenés à subir de
plein fouet les effets de précarisation
de la crise sanitaire et économique
est ce que nous craignons c'est
qu'aujourd'hui de nombreuses personnes
nouvelles basculent dans la pauvreté
nous estimons avec d'autres associations
qu'il y aura probablement un million de
personnes en plus en situation de
pauvreté en france en 2020
après la mise sous cloche du pays au
printemps l'économie à redémarrer au
ralenti chômage partiel baisse
d'activité saisonnière
de nombreuses personnes sont fragilisées
par la situation économique
dans un tel scénario l'alimentation est
souvent le premier poste de dépense
sacrifier sur le terrain les
associations observe déjà les premiers
effets de la crise vous voir arriver des
nouveaux publics qui font appel à l'aide
alimentaire on a beaucoup d'étudiants
qui qui ont pu pas pu travailler cet été
parce que souvent dans la restauration
les hôtels ça fonctionnait pas comme
avant ils peuvent pas avoir de petits
boulots complémentaire au cours de
l'année donc financièrement ils sont
très justes et sont obligés de se
tourner vers l'aide alimentaire on a eu
des vagues de licenciements depuis cet
été et on sait que la première raison de
faire appel à l'aide alimentaire saine
chômage pour faire face à la situation
emmanuel macron annoncé lors de son
allocution du 14 octobre dernier
plusieurs mesures spécifiques aux foyers
les plus précaires encore insuffisant
selon de nombreuses associations qui
réclament la création d'un revenu
minimum garanti pour tous évalués à 890
euros par mois et par personne
des manifestations en arménie contre
l'accord de paix signé pour le haut
karabakh un accord qui a mis fin je vous
le rappelle à six semaines de conflit
meurtrier
près de 2000 soldats de maintien de la
paix russes vont être déployés dans les
zones disputées une question de survie
pour la république autoproclamée à
majorité arménienne
le président français a également promis
d'y envoyer de l'aide humanitaire on
voit cela tout de suite à erevan avec
notre envoyé spécial kirill coty comme
un bon soir kirill vous êtes à erevan
y at-il toujours des manifestants dans
les rues ce soir bonsoir magali et bien
oui effectivement les rassemblements se
poursuivent à erevan la capitale
arménienne aujourd'hui entre 1500 et
2000 personnes s'étaient retrouvées sur
la place de la liberté à proximité de
l'opéra rassemblement plutôt
qu'allemands pas de débordements plus
que cela entre cinq et dix personnes
interpellées par les forces de l'ordre
selon nos sources il semblerait que les
erevan est plutôt que de chercher une
quelconque confrontation avec les forces
de l'ordre étaient plutôt descendus dans
les rues pour crier leur désarroi leur
incompréhension après la décision par le
premier ministre nicolas pas de signal
de signer l'accord de cessez le feu avec
bakou sous la médiation de moscou les
manifestants scandaient notamment le
slogan pas de xi'an traître et considère
en effet qu'il s'agit d'une trahison
d'un abandon du haut karabagh par les
autorités j'ai eu l'occasion par exemple
de discuter avec un chauffeur de taxi
qui était de très bonne humeur très
jovial et lorsque je lui ai demandé son
avis sur la situation sa mine est devenu
directement grave il m'a dit c'est d'une
tristesse absolue et nous avons honte
nous les arméniens c'est donc un
sentiment honte dont il m'a parlé
pourtant le premier ministre a fait
savoir que la décision du cessez le feu
n'était pas une capitulation mais
qu'elle avait été prise en tenant compte
de facteurs complexes et dans le but de
préserver la sécurité du peuple arménien
une sécurité qui dans le haut-karabagh
sera désormais assurée par moscou le
président russe vladimir poutine s'est
exprimé aujourd'hui à ce sujet et selon
lui est bien en signant cet accord
le pire a été évité je vous propose de
l'écouter conformément à la déclaration
le contingent russe des forces du
maintien de la paix est déployée le long
de la ligne de contact et le long du
soi-disant corridor de latchine il est à
noter que la région du haut karabagh
fait face à de graves problèmes
humanitaires qu on vient de nous
présenter à l'issue des combats
le nombre des victimes notamment parmi
les civils à dépasser 4000 personnes
plus de 8000 personnes sont blessées
selon différentes sources
il y a des dizaines de milliers de
réfugiés l'infrastructure civile et de
nombreux sites culturels ont été
détruits afin d'aider les habitants de
la région dans la résolution des
problèmes les plus pertinents j'estime
nécessaire de créer un centre
interministériel d'intervention
humanitaire et vous l'avez compris
magali ce n'est pas pour autant que les
arméniens ici à yerevan accepte cette
décision puisque de nouveaux
rassemblements sont prévus dans les
jours à venir
merci beaucoup kirill pour toutes ces
précisions kirill kotick offres en
direct des revan en arménie
de possibles crimes de guerre après le
massacre de civils dans la région du
tigré en ethiopie c'est ce que craint
l'onu qui a demandé une enquête
indépendante c'est la première fois
qu'un grand nombre de morts civils est
rapportée depuis le visu le 4 novembre
dernier de ce conflit qui oppose le
gouvernement du premier ministre au
front populaire de libération du tigre
est écouté alors que les détails des
massacres présumés rapporté par amnesty
international à mes cadres à dans le sud
ouest du tigre et n'ont pas encore été
entièrement vérifiée
la haute commissaire demande une enquête
complète s'il est confirmé qu'ils ont
été délibérément perpétrés par des
participants au combat actuel ces
meurtres de civils constituerait bien
sûr des crimes de guerre et il faut
qu'une enquête indépendante soit menée
pour que les responsables rendent
pleinement compte de ce qui s'est passé
michelle bachelet a averti que si les
forces régionales du tigre et les forces
du gouvernement éthiopien continuent sur
leur lancée la situation risque de
dégénérer en une spirale incontrôlable
entraînant de lourdes pertes en vies
humaines et des destructions ainsi que
des déplacements massifs à l'intérieur
même de l'ethiopie et au delà des
frontières des négociations sur la libye
aujourd'hui en tunisie discussions
internes libyennes qui se poursuivent au
lendemain d'un accord préliminaire signé
entre les parties sur la tenue de
prochaines élections des partis qui
doivent établir une feuille de route
afin d'organiser ces élections sous à 18
mois au maximum
mais également mettre en place un
exécutif unifiée il y as en libye je
vous le rappelle un gouvernement d'union
nationale qui est basée à tripoli et qui
s'opposent depuis plusieurs mois aux
forces du maréchal haftar l'homme fort
de l'est libyen
des avancées qui demeure années au moins
néanmoins un fragile puisque mardi un
haut responsable de ce
moment d'union nationale a été empêché
d'atterrir dans la ville de syrte alors
que des tractations étaient également en
cours dans cette ville libyenne
voyez à présent
et voyez à présent l'analyse de michel
scarbonchi ancien député européen et
consultant au moyen orient
les deux hommes forts de la libye
actuellement sont pour tripoli monsieur
bachaga l'ancien ministre de l'intérieur
et de la défense
et pour le port de bengazi bien sûr le
maréchal haftar à partir du moment où
ces deux hommes sont d'accord pour
arriver à un accord de paix nous aurons
la paix le problème jusqu'à présent
c'était monsieur farrage qui bloquait
tout farrage n'était plus crédible
puisqu'il était pour la grande majorité
des libyens l'homme qui avait vendu la
libye à la turquie donc il pouvait plus
être représentatifs bien qu'il soit
premier ministre de l'onu
bien sûr qu'il ya la volonté d'imposer
toujours pour certains une solution
militaire mais vous ayez le choix de
syrte
si il y à un nouvelle assemblée un
nouvel exécutif une nouvelle assemblée
nationale
il était proposé qu'au lieu d'être à
tripoli ou à bengazi pour départager les
deux camps on le mettrait à syrte syrte
qui était la ville de hue de kadhafi
donc une symbolique forte et c'est la
fin de ce journal merci de votre
fidélité on se retrouve dans 30 minutes
rester avec
[Musique]